ALEX RUSSELL: Good afternoon.
Hi, I'm Alex Russell.
I'm a software engineer at
Google and I work on a product
called Google Chrome Frame.
And I'm here today to
tell you all about it.
Google Chrome Frame, in a
nutshell, is a plugin for
internet explorer that lets
you use HTML5 right now.
That's sort of the simplest
explanation I can come up
with about Chrome Frame.
It lets you use HTML5 today, no
interruptions, no questions
about backwards compatibility.
You can start building things
with HTML5 without worrying
about how you are going
support old versions of IE.
We'll talk through the rest of
this talk about how you can use
it, how it works, how it's
compatible with all the rest of
the content that you might
already have on your internet,
or that your clients might have
when they're using
legacy browsers.
But, to be a little more
technically accurate about it,
Google Chrome Frame is a plugin
built on the open source
Chromium project.
And it is an internet
explorer plugin.
Its implemented as a browser
helper object, and we'll talk
a little bit later about what
that is and how it works.
It lets you, as the developer
choose whether or not you
would like your page to be
rendered in Chrome Frame.
And, if a user has Chrome Frame
installed, they'll see it.
So users and developers both
get a choice in determining how
a page is rendered when they
have Chrome Frame installed,
or you're targeting it.
And, maybe the most important
part of about Chrome Frame, is
that for organizations and
users who have legacy content,
legacy systems, or legacy
browsers, it allows the content
that they need to continue to
work, to continue to work on
the browsers that
they have today.
So, before we get into the
details and I tell you all
about how it works, and why it
works and all of that, I want
to show you a couple demos.
The first, of course,
is this presentation.
So for those of you who are
unfamiliar with Chrome Frame as
a product, the simplest way
to think about it is that
everything outside Chrome Frame
is IE like you normally expect.
So what we're seeing
here is a presentation
being rendered in IE8.
As you would normally see IE,
the tool bars are the same.
I can come up here and I can go
onto the tools and the menus,
and everything is sort of
the same as you'd expect.
But, if I come in here and I
right-click on this menu, we'll
note that the right-click menu
is not the right-click menu
from internet explorer.
This is the right-click menu
from Chrome, more or less.
In fact, all the tools, the
developer tools, the great,
wonderful, hugely productive
web inspector, that's
available, including the
command line console, resource
inspection, audits, the
console, all that stuff is
available to you as a web
developer when you are using
Chrome Frame inside of
internet explorer.
And again, from the user's
perspective this is just IE.
I can open new tabs.
I can navigate to new URLs and
if I navigate to a URL thats
not rendered in Google Chrome
Frame, one that hasn't opted
in, say Google.com-- there it
is - so Google.com is a webpage
that hasn't yet opted in to
rendering for Google
Chrome Frame.
If I come back here and I
right-click on this menu again,
we'll see that this is the
normal IE right-click menu.
This is same thing I would get
if I was just navigating on the
web with internet
explorer today.
So, Google Chrome Frame allows
pages optionally to opt
in to this rendering.
Let's look at a couple other
demos very quickly here.
Go back to full screen.
So Youtube, as you may have
seen yesterday, has announced
support for HTML5.
So what we're seeing here is
the HTML5 version of Youtube
running with the video tag, the
audio support system that you'd
normally expect, running one of
my favorite Google Chrome ads,
in Chrome Frame using native
HTML5 audio and video.
So, as you saw yesterday,
the WebM codec is going to
be supported in Chrome.
When that's available that will
be in Chrome Frame as well.
So, new features that show up
in the platform show up in
Chrome Frame almost
immediately.
And you can start targetting
them for sites you develop
against HTML5 in internet
explorer today.
So Youtube's pretty hot.
That's great.
We can use HTML5 audio
and video tags.
We can use high-performance
codecs that Chrome supports
including H264, osgViewer and
now WebM as a great option.
And, the standard
support is outstanding.
So, for those of you who are
web developer dorks in the
room, this should mean
something to you.
How many is that?
Everybody?
Nobody?
Is this good?
This is Acid3 passing
100 out of 100 in IE8.
And, that's not because IE8
supports the Acid3 test.
In fact.
If we copy this URL we give
this a go, normally the Acid3
page isn't sending the header
or the meta-tag that we'll
talk about in a minute.
And this is the normal
experience that you will get.
This is sort of indicated of
the standard support that you
should expect for apps that
are natively targeting
legacy browsers.
So, it would be better
if we could do better.
So Chrome Frame allows you
to start targeting these
features almost immediately.
So the question becomes, let's
assume that I could start
building a application today.
And, I could start targeting
Google Chrome Frame.
What sorts of things
could I use?
I'm a web developer.
I started on a project coming
from a web development
background and I've had this
sort of continual process of
un-learning and re-learning
how to do my job as
a web developer.
Part of that has been there's a
whole series of features that I
heard about maybe a year, or
two, or three ago, that I sort
of put back in the back of the
attic and said yea, that
will be great someday
when I can use it.
And part of my job now, is to
dust those things off and
realize that if I target Chrome
Frame I can start using them
almost immediately, and it's
a very long list indeed.
You may have seen some of the
wonderful HTML5 presentations
already, but the list of things
that we can start building with
today if we could target
modern browsers is really
sort of eye opening.
And each one of these, could
maybe revolutionize a
single application.
Web GL is coming.
SVG and canvas support
are already in Chrome.
All the annimations that you're
seeing in this deck are done
with CSS annimations
and transforms.
There isn't Javascript
driving any
of this.
The layout of this
presentation, the drop shadows,
the rounded corners, that's all
being done with CSS.
There aren't large
amounts of images.
In fact, I think there's
3, maybe 5 images in this
entire presentation.
And 2 or 3 of them
are diagrams.
Everything else are
background images.
The sort of
dynamic range that you've got
available in modern CSS, HTML
and DOM is really impressive.
And, in fact, it sort of
changes the way we think about
building applications entirely.
And this sort of backlog of
features that we can start
targeting, if you go to one of
the HTML5 presentations, or
have been to one of them,
you'll sort of understand
what we mean.
But the feature list, the back
log of things that we can start
to do is really powerful.
So, the question becomes, from
many folks, why shouldn't we
just install Google Chrome.
And, I think the
answer is you should.
Please do.
As a developer, I like it.
web inspector, as you
saw earlier, is awesome.
It gives me the ability to
develop and debug things almost
as fast as I can anywhere else.
The Javascript engine
is outstanding.
Webkit is an amazingly layout
and rendering engine.
It has wonderful features, some
of which we haven't even begun
to scratch the surface
of collectively.
And as a user, I like Chrome.
Chrome is a wonderful browser.
It has great security features.
The multiprocess model keeps
things from crashing and going
badly, all over the place when
maybe one tab goes tilt or
maybe one plugin decides
to chew a bunch of CPU.
So, Chrome is a great
user experience.
However, a lot of organizations
aren't in a position
to necessarily switch.
So, you may have
worked in a bank.
Or, been to a university,
where there's a centrally
administered configuration
of windows.
You're not allowed to install
anything as a user, or if you
are, it's wiped when you log
into the box the next time.
Many organizations and users
have set up where even if
they're allowed to install
something at a user level, it
may not be available to them
the next time they log in.
So, for those organizations,
they'll have to adopt
a new browser on-mass.
They'll have to adapt
their systems to deal
with a new browser.
And many of them are scared of
changing a lot of systems that
they might have bought from
a vendor who may have gone
defunct or who may not support
new versions, or who may not
support new versions or for
whom buying a new version that
supports modern web standards
might be relatively expensive.
So, they may not be willing
to move all of their
infrastructure all at once
to support a new browser.
Similarly you could imagine,
let's take a small
regional bank.
They have an IT system
that they bought from a
vendor the late 1990's.
It uses Active-x controls
and they're critically
dependent on it.
It may not be the most secure
thing that they've got, but
it's something that they're
critically, as a business,
dependent on it.
They can't get away from it.
So for these sort of
organizations, going to them
and saying internet explorer
for those applications, but
then you should train your
users, to go use a different
browser for other
applications, seems like a
difficult sell to me.
If you could tell me how to
do it, we'd love to know.
But, it seemed like a difficult
proposition to make for
a lot of organizations.
Specifically the side by side
installation management hassles
for users calling the support
desk or asking IT to come to
help them figure out which
browser to use where is a
daunting prospect for a
lot of organizations.
So for the organizations that
can, and for users that can,
Chrome, and other modern
browsers are a great
choice, and that's Plan A.
We want users to install and
use modern browsers, because
they get the full benefits of
modern experience, whereas they
might not with legacy browsers.
But many organizations can't.
So, Google Chrome Frame is a
stop-gap solution in many ways.
It gives us the rendering
engine v8, webkit, modern
HTML and CSS, HTML5.
And, it puts it inside the
UI of Chrome, oh, sorry
of internet explorer
as we saw before.
So it does this but it tries to
do this in a way that's not
gonna break existing content.
So you could imagine that we
could have written a plugin
that when you installed it,
it would would render every
web page in Google Chrome.
But, Chrome doesn't
support ActiveX Controls.
We won't support
Active X Controls.
Chrome supports plugins, but we
support them out of process.
There's a lot of different
differences between certain
kinds of legacy content and the
modern web and it's impossible
for Chrome to support
them all natively.
So, instead of that, Chrome
Frame allows you to have the
pages that render in the Chrome
Frame mode only show up in
that mode when the
developer opts in.
At the same time, users don't
see that when they don't have
Chrome Frame installed
or enabled.
If Chrome Frame is enabled,
those pages will switch, but if
they don't have Chrome Frame
installed, it just falls back
to the normal IE
user experience.
So, that means that no page is
ever going to be ambushed.
No page is ever going to render
in Chrome Frame that didn't
expect to be rendered
in Chrome Frame.
You, as a developer, a
web developer, opt in
to this treatment.
Developers opt in per page.
So, let's say that I'm on
a domain, and I build
a web application.
You can imagine a different
design choice, where we might
have said one page in this
domain wants to be enabled
to render in Chrome Frame.
So we should opt them all in.
That's not how it works.
Every individual page gets an
equal choice about whether
or not it wants to be
rendered in Chrome Frame.
That means, that you can have
a log pages that uses IE's
rendering engine, and maybe
be your main application is
rendering in Chrome Frame.
We'll talk a little bit later
on about how we work to make
sure that experience is
coherent between those
two different pages.
There's also no
blanket rendering.
That means an administrator
does have an option to push out
a policy that would make many
pages all render in Chrome
Frame but generally speaking
that's not how its configured,
and thats not how it
works out of the box.
And, Chrome Frame most
critically won't
break the internet.
It's there to help you over the
hump until such time as you can
decided to use or deploy
a more modern browser.
But until then, this allows you
to continue to work on those
legacy systems, phasing them
out and moving along your users
and your IT systems in an
orderly fashion to
a better future.
How would you as a web
developer opt in to
this better world?
It's really easy.
The best way is to add a single
HTTP header to the pages that
you'd like to be rendered
in Chrome Frame.
So, for many applications, this
is a single or maybe several
lines in an apache
configuration file or an ISS
configuration file.
In fact, Wordpress.com rolled
out this header in a change to
their HTTP daemon last week
across all of their sites.
It was a single change and
it went out everywhere.
So, for many organizations that
don't have control over
templates for applications that
they may have purchased, this
is the easiest and simplest
way to make it happen.
But, as a
web developer, this may not
be the most convenient.
So, we also support
a meta-tag version.
This X-UA-Compatible flag, by
the way, was introduced with
the internet explorer 8, as a
way for IE to help switch
different versions of its own
internal rendering engine.
We're just piggybacking on this
sort of already existing usage
of an extension header to allow
you to specify Chrome as one
of the options in the list.
It's worth noting that when
you specify Chrome along with
other options, the Chrome
option wins, so you get Chrome
and then you fall back to IE.
So, there's pluses and
minuses to these methods.
The header, the HTTP header,
is the most reliable way of
triggering Chrome Frame
across your sites.
When you use the meta-tag, it
has to be in the first 1K of
the document, but the header
doesn't have that restriction.
Since headers, we see them all,
it's easier potentially to
configure it for your entire
site and maybe slightly faster.
It's unfortunate though that
you will have require a change
to either your scripts or your
HTTP daemon or some other part
of your infrastructure that can
set headers in order
to make this work.
You can't just open up a text
file, type some HTML into and
then have Chrome Frame rendered
with the header mode.
You have to use the meta-tag.
You can use them together.
The first one wins obviously.
And in many places you may not
be able to change your HTTP
headers, so imagine that I've
got a lock down Apache
configuration which doesn't
have HT access file enabled.
It may not be possible for
me as a user or a developer
to set differente headers.
The meta-tag method is
great for prototyping.
This is the easiest way to get
started with Chrome Frame .
You just put this at the smack
dab at the top of your page,
just inside the head element in
your document and it's easy to
it going with, and you can use
it in conjunction with the
other values for
X-UA-Compatible
that IE supports.
It's a little bit harder
potentially to configure this
across an entire site, so if
you've got a very large
templated application,
sometimes it's difficult to
make sure that meta-tag
occurs in the very
top of the document.
Say some other include puts
content in the top of the
document well before the
first k, and pushes you
out of that first 1k.
you may not trigger
as reliably.
And in some places, you
may not have had control
over applications or
site wide headers.
So, you have choices,
you can use them both.
You can use of one or the
other, but just be aware
of the pluses and minuses
when you go to use it.
So the question, of course,
is what happens when Chrome
Frame isn't installed?
You get the regular IE
rendering of a document.
And, in fact, lets go and look
and see what happens there.
Chrome Frame depends not only
on being installed but also on
being enabled, so we can
come in here and we can
disable Chrome Frame.
So, I'm going to disable that.
This, unfortunately, will
require browser restart because
enabling, and disabling does.
The install process
doesn't, however.
And, just one second.
Users tend not enable and
disable add ons, so we want
to make sure both aspects
of it are disabled.
So let's go back, load
IE, without Chrome Frame
enabled in any way.
We're seeing here
is this prompt.
This prompt is provided by a
Script called CF Install.
But again, if we come back and
we inspect this page, we can
see that this is the
IE context menu.
This page is simply being
rendered in internet explorer
when Chrome Frame isn't
available or installed.
So, what we've got here is
the fall back scenerio.
And, this prompt is not
something that happens
automatically.
This is something that you
choose to do in your document.
So, I'll go back and re-enable
Chrome Frame, and I'll
show you how that works.
What we're seeing here is CF
Install, that script actually
detected that Chrome Frame was
enabled while it was on the
page and refreshed
the page for me.
I didn't even have to do.
That's how the install
flow works, by the way.
Once you install Chrome
Frame, the page is
automatically refreshed.
Users don't even have to
refresh their browsers.
So, while I'm forwarding to the
slide that I was on; the
downslide of each HTML slides;
the CF Install script is a
script that you add into
your page optionally.
It's not there by default.
It's something you have to do
if you'd like to prompt your
users to install for Chrome
Frame when it's not
available by default.
So if we go and we view the
page source, again we get
Chrome's beautiful rendering
of source I hope.
I really hope.
Oh, God, please smile upon me.
Oh, not so much.
You will have to forgive me.
I'm going to switch to Chrome
for the rest the presentation.
I apologize.
I try something that was
a little bit risky,
I paid for it.
So the CF Install script that
we that we were just looking,
page source, that's
what I wanted.
I've added it to the
bottom of my page here.
So, as you can see, at the top
of my page there is the X2A
compatible meta-tag, which has
the exact same value that we
would put in the HTTP header.
So, in this case, I can pass
HTML file around and every user
who sees it can experience
Chrome Frame if they've
got installed.
At the very bottom of my
document here, we've got
a little bit of script
that's what is called
a conditional comment.
And, a conditional comment is
an IE specific way for making
the internet explorer
understand only particular
pieces of content in the page.
So, in this case, we were
saying, if the document is
being rendered in internet
explorer, which is say, we
weren't flipped into
Chrome Frame mode.
We'd like you to go and request
this script off of the Ajax's
API content distribution
network, which Google hosts.
So this API, this Javascript
file, like many other
Javascript APIs, JQuery, JoJo,
that you might have heard of,
are hosted by us on our edge
cached CDN, so hopefully
not to slow you down.
And there's a single line there
at the bottom called CFInstall
dot check, which says when you
detect that Chrome Frame hasn't
been installed, use that
overlay that we saw
there earlier.
Use that overlay and pop
up that prompt, to have
your users install this.
So if we were to put the
meta-tag or the header in the
document but not include
CFInstall we'd get best
effort rendering.
That means that if the user
has Chrome Frame installed it
would be rendered that way.
And, if not it would
just fall back.
For a lot of sites
that's a great option.
So you can have the
meta-tag without any
additional friction.
It's a really simple one line
change to your website.
And, if your users is have
Chrome Frame, maybe they get
better experience, or they
will get better experience.
If they don't, no big deal.
On the other hand, if your
building something that targets
HTML5 features explicitly,
CFInstall and this 2 line
change to your document, or, in
this case, 4 with the
conditional comment is a great
way to help you make sure the
your documents work everywhere
and that users get the
best experience possible.
More fun with HTML slides.
So we just saw the CFInstall
script at work overlay prompt
asks users to install Chrome
Frame and it's a general case
it doesn't require users
to restart their browser.
So, on the service side, let's
say you got some Code that's
detecting and potentially
sending different content
down to the user.
You'd like to know whether
or not your users can
see Chrome Frame.
And the way we make this
possible for you, is we
extend the user agent header
that the clients send.
Now we don't extend it all the
time, so when Chrome Frame is
disabled, but installed, we
don't augment the user
agent header with this
string at the end.
This tells you that Chrome
Frame is available.
That its IE with Chrome Frame
and what version of Chrome
Frame you're using.
Generally speaking, all Chrome
Frame users are going to be on
the latest version, because we
use the same auto update system
that Google Chrome does, which
means that most users are going
to be on the very
latest released within
weeks of release.
So, if you've got a server-side
script, that's detecting script
or some code that's detecting
the user agent, you can look
for this to know that you can
send the meta-tag or the header
for users that it have got it,
and maybe direct them to a
different experienc otherwise.
That's how Google Wave does it.
So, if Google Wave does this,
so if Google Wave detects this
it lets users right
on through to Wave.
On the other hand, if they
don't have it, they ask users
to get a better browser or to
install Chrome Frame as a
result because Wave just isn't
designed for browsers that
don't have HTML5 support.
Again it's worth noting that
the user agent is only
extended when Chrome Frame
is installed and active.
If we disable the browser
helper object or disable the
plugin, but it is installed, we
don't send so, you're never
going to get see that header
from a client that can't
handle Chrome Frame content.
At the same time, we don't want
to make it so that you have to
change your scripts on the
inside of your documents to be
aware of Google Chrome Frame so
while we might send an
augmented internet explorer
user agent on the network on
the inside when you query it
from Javascript and say
navigator dot user agent, the
user agent you'll get back is
Chrome's user agent, so if you
have existing scripts that
understand Chrome, or are not
doing feature detection, but
might be doing user agent
detection instead, Chrome Frame
looks exactly like Google
Chrome from the inside.
No changes necessary there.
All of your Javascript
should continue to work.
So, the key take-away here is
that so far, right, Google
Chrome Frame is this little
rendering area where the main
document is and everything
else works exactly the way it
should in internet explore.
The integration goes
deeper than that.
Instead of just rendering a
document when we're asked to
render document, we make sure
that we use the same coookies,
so that when you request a
cookie in Javascript say, from
a document that's being
rendered in Chrome Frame, you
see the same cookies that were
sent to internet explorer
earlier in the session.
At the same time, we don't
use a separate cache.
We use internet
explorer's cache.
When you make a request across
the document, for a document or
a resource that came across the
wire earlier, you're going to
get the cache behavior from IE.
If you have Chrome installing
on the box, and Chrome frame
we will continue to use IE's
cache, not Chrome's cache.
That means that when you clear
the cache, in internet
explorer, the cache from IE
goes away, and Chrome Frame
doesn't leave trails
behind either.
We also have the same
network behavior.
That means that when we make a
request for a cell if you've
got clients' search installed,
if you've got a special proxy
installed, if you've got a
pack file, that stuff
all works as well.
We use internet
explorer's networking.
Now, there's a couple
of caveats here.
That means that some network
behaviors are slightly
different in Chrome Frame then
they are under Google Chrome.
For instance, Google Chrome
allows you to have 6
network connections up to
any particular host.
That's great if you are doing
common style applicatins
or server push messaging.
On the other hand, internet
explorer only gives you 2 on
versions before IE7 and the
result is that we might see
prefetching behavior that looks
like Google Chrome from Chrome
Frame at the network level.
When pass it off to IE we'll
get that 2 connection
limit in force.
So, generally speaking, things
look at the network level like
Chrome except when we hit some
hard limits that are at a level
lower than Chrome frame in
order to make sure that things
work that we expect them to.
We respect the end private mode
for Google that internet
explorer users in IE8, and
we use Chrome's incognito
mode when that happens.
So pages that are rendered
in private browsing, in
IE trigger incognito mode
for Chrome Frame tabs.
Similarly we respect cache
clearing, cookie clearing, all
of the same things that you'd
expect to have happened for
any IE hosted web page.
So, how does this all work?
Briefly speaking, navigation
begins when a user cllicks on a
link, types in an address in
the location bar, and hits
enter in some other way, opens
a short cut that's going to
navigate internet explorer
to a different page.
When that happens, there's a
small component sitting inside
of internet explorer, the
browser helper object that
we talked about earlier.
And, that allows us to observe
the request and as we saw
earlier, we augment the user
agent string with that Chrome
slash version number when it
goes out to the network.
And when the request comes
back, we try to determine
whether not it was that
destined for Chrome or if
it was destine for
internet explorer.
If it's destined for Chrome
Frame, the Chrome rendering
engine, then we create an
active document server, render
the page in Chrome, like you
would expect, say with a
full page PDF which is the
experience that we saw earlier.
And if not, we just passed
it right on through to IE.
So, the simple way to think
about this, is that there is a
process for internet explore
so this sort of resembles
IE6 and 7 on Windows XP.
It's a little bit more
complicated because the there's
a multiprocess model there, but
for simplicity sake, let's
think about a single
process internet explorer.
So, IE has series of components
down at the networking disk
Javascript layers that all sort
of collaborate together and
when internet explorer loads,
there's a supported mechanism
call browser helper objects
which allowed you, as the
developer, to register some
component to load with
internet explorer.
There's a very tiny component
that's part of Chrome Frame
that loads with IE
in this mechanism.
So when Chrome Frame is
initialized, this small, tiny
helper object is loaded when
internet explorer starts,
but that doesn't mean that
Chrome Frame starts though.
Generally speaking, when you're
navigating around the web, with
IE and Chrome Frame is enabled,
this tiny component is
observing what happens on the
network to try to determine
whether or not these requests
are destined for Chrome Frame.
Generally speaking, they
probably won't be.
Because most pages today
don't target Chrome Frame.
So, what happens a the page
does want to be rendered
in Chrome Frame?
We observe the response see
that should be rendered in
Chrome Frame and we fire up
Chrome's multiprocess model.
That means that when a document
is created that wants to be
rendered in Chrome Frame,
We launch Chrome.
We create a rendered process,
which is to say, sort of the
fancy way of saying, a separate
OS process that renders things
in webkit, and make sure that
happens inside a sandbox.
We plumb all that through
to an in process active
document server.
For those of you who don't know
what active document is, it's
sort of the IE mechanism or the
windows mechanism for rendering
some other content type that IE
doesn't know about already.
Think, PDF, or a flash object.
So, as you can see here, we
have the same benefits of
Chrome's multiprocess
architecture in play in this
model as you would when
you're rendering documents
in Chrome directly.
That means that tabs the
crash don't take down
the entire browser.
Security issues are mitigated
because things are rendered
inside Chrome's sandbox, which
means that vulnerabilities in
webkit don't turn into
vulnerabilities in Chrome
most of the time.
And this architecture has
several other benefits.
Obviously, when you start up
internet explorer, it's not
slowed down significantly
because we're not loading
Chrome along with it.
We only load Chrome when you
ask for a page rendered
in Chrome Frame.
We also have very small
communication channels between
the browser helper object, that
small extension that's loaded
with internet explorer,
and Chrome Frame, and
the Chrome browser.
That means that the attack
surface area for potential
attackers is pretty small.
And we do a lot of work to
make sure that the Chrome
architecture works the way it
should in this model as well.
We have separate infrastructure
for making sure that when
we launch Chrome, you don't
see a window that pops up.
And we talk about that
later in the Q&A
if you are interested.
What users can benefit
from Chrome Frame?
Generally speaking, the
most widely-used versions
of IE are supported.
We only support Windows XP
Service Pack 2 and above
because IE on SP1 and below,
didn't support the sandbox
[? incrivatives ?]
that we need to make sure
the renders can render
content responsibly.
So that cuts out Windows
2000 and earlier
versions of Windows XP.
But generally speaking, I think
of most organizations are
off of those versions.
The major caveat of course,
with Chrome Frame is that it
does require administrator
privileges to install today.
I can tell you that when we hit
beta, we will be making MSI
packages and group policy
templates available for
administrators to roll out
Chrome Frame across
their enterprises.
So many of users who are in
lock down configurations may
not be able to benefit from the
per-user install nature of
Chrome today, and so the
easiest way for them to get it
is going to be through their
administrators rolling out
Chrome Frame and we plan to
make it easy for
them to do that.
When the user does encounter
the Chrome Frame initial
installer, we saw that they
don't have to restart their
browser in order to install
Chrome Frame and
start using it.
And, the initial
downloan is very small.
We use a system called Omaha,
which is our installer package.
And, the initial
download is 500k.
The rest of it happens sort of
in an automated fashion so we
insure that there's a minimum
of user hassle when
installing Chrome.
So, for those of you who are C
hackers, windows
people, maybe, anyone?
All right!
Yes!
Chrome Frame is implemented
as an ActiveX control and
an active document server.
That means that if you're
building a desktop application
that can use an embedded HTML
rendering engine, you can use
Chrome Frame to do that.
As you might expect we have a
set of supported interfaces.
We registered these at the
system level, which means that
when Chrome Frame is installed,
any application can use them.
They are scriptible and the
details of the interface that
we support and are supporting,
is available in the Chrome
tab, that IDL file.
It's just a regular windows IDL
file that you'd expect to see.
And, if you have questions
about that, we have an
active mailing list that
we can help you with.
The major caveat in all of this
is that the activex control and
the active document server
don't support synchronous
access to the document
object model.
Unlike HTML, we can't provide
you with that use-ability
nice-ity, because it provides
challenges for synchronization
across the multiprocess
architecture for Google Chrome.
Instead, we support HTML5 post
message and on message system
as a way for you to send
messages to content host
inside of Chrome Frame.
And, get messages back out.
That's available in either
the ActiveX or the active
document versions.
So, we mentioned earlier that
the Google Chrome Frame
doesn't start up from
Chrome when IE launches.
So, what does it do instead?
So, it launches that small
browser helper object and when
it detects that a page is
destined for Chrome Frame,
it launches Chrome then.
Chrome launches very fast.
That's the good news.
The bad news is that
it still takes time.
We're not doing it up so we're
not slowing down IE's launch.
But your page might
see a small hit.
So, what happens after that
hit turns out to be just
as important to your page.
In some applications that are
Javascript heavy we've seen
we've seen the cold start up
time for Chrome be totally
more than made up for by
the performance benefits
from V8 and modern CSS.
We're working as hard as we can
to reduce the start up time and
the warm start up time is
perfectly acceptable today.
It's the order of hundreds
of milliseconds.
So, the second page to use
Chrome Frame in a session
doesn't have to pay
the same cost.
And, so modern CSS, DNS
prefetching which is to say,
when we encounter a page, we
look down the page to see which
resources we're going to need
in the future and we fire off
those requests at the DNS level
early, so that we know that
you're going to need them.
You're going to be looking them
up and we can sort of pre-warm
in the caches on the
OS level for those.
And, between all those things,
we tend to do very well
in terms of performance.
So, now what?
Well, Google Chrome Frame was
released to the developer
channel last fall,
late September.
And it's been in that developer
channel ever since which is
sort of like our way
of saying Alpha.
The Google Chrome team has
supported these three different
channels, developer, beta, and
unstable since Google Chrome
was initially released.
And the waterfall sort of looks
like we release things from
trunk on a very frequent basis
in the developer channel, make
it branch at some point.
That's beta.
We keep fixing it and
then it goes to stable.
So Chrome Frame is on the
exact same trajectory.
And I'm happy to announce that
in several weeks we'll be
releasing the beta for you.
So, Google Chrome Frame in
several weeks, will be
available for wider use, will
be making MSI and group policy
templates available for
administrators to begin rolling
out inside of enterprises and
many applications are going to
start targeting Chrome Frame.
We are in the developer
channel today.
You can go,
and download Chrome Frame.
You can start using it.
You can start
developing against it.
And we support all of the same
features that Google Chrome
does in the developer channel.
We track, from releases
more or less day for day.
Today, the team is working very
hard to improve the startup
performance so that the your
pages get the full benefit
of those high-performance
Javascript HTML and CSS engines
without any of the lag for
start-up and we're continue to
polish the feature set of
Chrome Frame to ensure that it
works exactly the way you
expect it to inside of IE.
That the back button works,
the print menus work,
that everything works the
way you expect it to.
We're sort of filling in
the menus, filling in the
right-click system, making sure
that all the systems work
exactly you think they should.
And, in order to make sure
that we are not missing any
features, we want your help.
We need your feedback and
would love for you to get
involved in the project.
As I mentioned earlier Google
Chrome Frame is a part of the
Chromium project,
so if you know C
, or if you're just a user who
wants to understand more about
it, we have a mailing list.
You can go find it and we'd be
happy to hear from you and
understand your needs.
So, you can get involved by
going to either the main
product site, Google.com slash
Chrome Frame where you can
install Chrome Frame directly,
or the Google code site, where
there is obviously links to the
mailing lists documentation
support resources available for
you to start using
Chrome frame.
And I just wanted to mention
that when the Beta does go out,
the developer channel will
still be available for you
to target features on.
There'll be a new developer
channel release that's made
available at the same time as
we did with Chrome and so join
the mailing list and keep
your eyes out for that.
I'll take some questions now
from the mikes and we'll see
what happened on the moderator.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You have mentioned a
behavior for, say, for example,
you have of friend set.
Is that partially like friends,
some of the friends could
partially be rendered by one
friend and the others rendered
by iframe kind of thing.
Your page have iframes, is that
possible for iframe rendering
using Chrome Frame and the
other traditional stuff?
ALEX RUSSELL: That's
a great question.
So, the answer is that Chrome
Frame operates at the top level
of the document, which is to
say, if an iframe wants to be
rendered into Chrome Frame, we
only try to pay attention to
top level navigations, We don't
switch into Chrome Frame
rendering for individual
subdocuments.
It's very difficult.
There's a lot of complexity
around the scripting
relationship between documents
that are in the same domain
through the web security model
and again we don't support that
synchronous DOM access, so we
might break scripts if one
script wanted to and
one script didn't.
It sounds uncommon, but it
happens in very large
organizations with a lot of
things hosted on the same
domain That said, the ActiveX
version is available.
You can use it on the
document individually.
It acts a lot like an iframe.
I don't recommend that you
target that unless you have no
other option, but if you have
questions, talk to me afterward
or join the mailing list and we
can talk you through easymap.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: My 2 questions are
both in moderator, but my top
priority feature is print
support, and I wasn't clear if,
with the Beta, is print support
available in the Beta?
ALEX RUSSELL: So the question
was print support for
Google Chrome Frame.
Print support is available.
It's available at the level of
Google Chrome's print support.
Which is to say its all right.
It could be better.
It could be significantly
better, but it's pretty good.
You can print Chrome Frame
documents today, if it
doesn't work let us know.
AUDIENCE: When you say today,
today, you mean today today.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yes, just to be
clear, we've been making new
releases on a weekly basis in
the developer channel since
the initial release.
So, we've been adding new
features, improving stability,
making sure that crashes are
reduced ever since then.
So it's not like we've
been sitting still.
So that if you checked it out a
couple months ago and it didn't
work that way try
installing today.
Give it another shot
and let us know.
AUDIENCE: I think the web
page still says it's not.
ALEX RUSSELL: Ah OK,
that's a to do it for me.
AUDIENCE: And the other
question is, what do you
think is still in the path?
Is it just fixing bugs in
quality fixes or are there
major components you think are
still needed before it becomes
stable, as opposed
to just beta?
ALEX RUSSELL: From my personal
use, the things that I care
most about are performance.
Once a page is rendered in
Google Chrome Frame it's as
fast as it is in Chrome,
which is outstanding.
Startup performance is
currently our largest
outstanding item on the
trajectory towards stable.
We want to make it so that you
don't even notice that Chrome
Frame is starting up and I
think we have a good shot at
making sure that happens.
Generally speaking, though
otherwise I'm happy with the
way the fit and finish are
today and I think that we will
be in stable, I can't promise
anything obviously, up
but hopefully shortly.
AUDIENCE: One last quick one,
I'm just reminding myself,
Google Chrome doesn't have
print preview, right?
Does that mean Google
Chrome Frame doesn't
have print preview?
ALEX RUSSELL: That's correct.
The question was yes, Google
Chrome Frame has support for
printing at the level
of Chrome today.
AUDIENCE: So, last time I
played with Chrome Frame, I was
trying to use the cross-origin
resource sharing, the XHR2, and
it totally crashed,
like everything.
It all just went, kaboom.
ALEX RUSSELL: Can you explain
the scenerio a little more?
Were you try to do that
in a single document?
AUDIENCE: Yes, this was
like two months ago.
Maybe it's change since then.
I didn't know if maybe a
network layer thing that IE
doesn't allow it, so Chrome
Frame can't allow it, but I had
a page where I was trying to do
post to another site using
XHR2 and it kaboomed.
ALEX RUSSELL: And were you
sending back any specific
headers regarding the policy
for display and subframes?
Or, were you simply sending
back I allowed this
cross-origin resource?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I was sending
back everything -- like it
works in other browsers and
it works in Chrome and
it works in Firefox.
ALEX RUSSELL: If that's
not working, its our bug.
Try it again.
We have updated Chrome Frame in
the meantime, but if it doesn't
work, try it in the Chrome
Developer Channel release.
And just file a bug, and let
us know that it's not working
for you and join the
mailing list and
we'll work it out.
AUDIENCE: But that that
should be working?
That's not a restriction.
ALEX RUSSELL: If the main page
is rendered in Google Chrome
Frame, yes, it should work.
AUDIENCE: I have few
very quick questions.
Number 1, does flash just work?
ALEX RUSSELL: Flash just works.
So, not only does it just work,
we're using the built-in flash
from Google Chrome so you may
have heard that several weeks
ago we announced that Google
Chrome is shipping Flash 10.1
as part of Chrome, so it auto
updates on the exact same
cycle that Chrome does.
So, you get the latest Flash,
and you get the built
in version of Flash.
AUDIENCE: OK and then when
you're going into beta, are you
going to be branding it as
Beta, because people
might be hesitant.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yes, we will.
When we go into
Beta. you'll know.
AUDIENCE: OK and then
pop up blockers.
How does that work?
ALEX RUSSELL: The question
was, how do pop up blockers
work in Chrome Frame.
Generally speaking, we intend
to attempt to plumb pop-up
requests back through internet
explorer, so in order to host a
separate window in a pop up, we
do have to ask internet
explorer to create to that
window for us, and then we
parent the new Chrome tab
inside it, and in
the background.
The Javascript relationship
between parented windows
should work correctly.
You should be able to sript
them, that's correct.
AUDIENCE: Can an IT Admin
specify which pages should
be loaded in Chrome Frame?
For example, if an IT Admin
wants to load Gmail or Docs,
through Chrome Frame instead
of having to instead of
having to change the HTML?
ALEX RUSSELL: The question
was a can I specify which
pages I'd liked to have
rendered that way.
The answer is, yes.
If you look at the
documentation for Chrome Frame
there is a series of registry
keys that we make available to
help you configure which pages
explicitly through
administrator policy you'd like
to have rendered
in Chrome Frame.
You should be careful though
for applications like Docs,
sites or Gmail where they may
be sending conditional content.
They are trying to optimize as
much as they can, so they may
not be sending the same content
to every browser and if they're
not savvyabout Chrome Frame,
and they are not already sort
of triggering Chrome Frame, you
may get yourself into to sort
of compatibility worries.
So, I'd recommend that if you
are going to do that, that only
for applications that you
control or have tested with.
And, if you do have problems
with Google applications,
let us know.
We would like to would like
to understand how you'd
like to use them.
How you'd like to see
that's deployed.
Also, also if you find the
registry keys we have made
available for that
configuration aren't
sufficient, again, we'd love to
hear from you now, while we
still a chance to
affect the beta.
AUDIENCE: real quickly,
the tough question.
We've pushed pretty hard
get all our clients onto
Firefox because of the IE.
Chrome works a lot faster than
Firefox with the Javascripts.
Is there a plan to have --
ALEX RUSSELL: So, the good news
is that all of the browsers
that have been participating in
the recent Javascript
performance race are
making huge strides.
So Javascript performance
in Firefox are miles
ahead of where they
were even a year ago.
And, thats part of the reasons
we started the Chrome project.
It was to make sure that we
could light a fire under this
process of competition.
So, most of the browsers that
don't have majority market
share are doing really well
keeping up with modern
standards, HTML5.
And, in fact, because as
I said earlier Plan A is
to get a better browser.
We what users to install and
use better browsers and to have
those browsers compete head on
to improve their features set.
So we're not going to be making
a full page version of Google
Chrome Frame available for
Firefox as far as I know.
Generally speaking, there
just isn't a great
reason to do it, right?
Firefox is doing a great job of
improving their performance and
compatibility story and we're
looking forward to working more
with them in the future to make
the web more open, and that
involves competing head on.
AUDIENCE: Does Chrome Frame
support Windows Authentication.
For example, internet web
pages that require --
ALEX RUSSELL: Does Chrome Frame
support Windows authentication?
And, TML authentication,
something like that?
I know we have an open bug NTM
authentication right now.
I can talk to you afterwards.
If you look through the
Chromium bug tracker in the
area Chrome Frame and TLM you
should find the bug, be able
to start and see how
we make progress.
We tend to knock out bugs
pretty fast so you'll get
updates on that bug as we
power through and fix it.
Eventually, it will work.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Wondering to what
extent if any, Google will try
to promote adoption of Chrome
Frame through it's
own websites?
ALEX RUSSELL: Well, Wave today
already does this so Wave today
does not support on any
version of internet explore
without Chrome Frame.
So, you would imagine that as
individual properties decide
that they want switch over to
using HTLM5 features, that
they will make an individual
decision about where their
cost benefit analysis lies.
And, hopefully, if Chrome Frame
becomes widely adopted it will
be easy for them to make that
choice but and that is up to
those individual apps teams.
And if you have a particular
app that you'd like to see
using Chrome Frame, I would
suggest that you
send them mail.
I'd love to hear, I'd love
to CC'ed on that too.
Thanks.
Are there othere questions?
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if this has been tried.
I haven't been following Chrome
Frame, but have you looked
at legacy mobile apps?
Like IE6 in most cases?
ALEX RUSSELL: Good question.
So, the legacy mobile
world is difficult.
Difficult not only in the sense
that it's much more difficult
to distribute software
onto those platforms.
I mean, it is internet explorer
in some very real sense, but
there's also a much more highly
constraint memory footprint.
Chrome is built for
modern systems.
We use the multiprocess
architecture because we have
enough memory to do it,
generally speaking.
I think most web developers
that I talk to treat Windows
Mobile's browser sort of
as the down level browser.
So if you are building a mobile
site, you have sort of like
your webkit based, and Opera
Experience up here and Firefox
up here, and then you have sort
of your down level experience.
I know a lot of people treat
Windows Mobile browser as
down level experience, and
that might be the right
way to think about.
The good news in the mobile
world is that things move
a lot faster, right?
We got sort of stuck in a
trough in terms of competition
on the desktop browser but
mobile handsets over a
relatively short clip, users
get new handsets every
-- I'm sorry --
AUDIENCE: --I'm referring to
the enterprise mobile space,
where it's not that quick.
ALEX RUSSELL: We have
not looked at it.
If you think that it's
something that would be
reasonable to do, we don't have
a port of Chrome to Windows CE
and we use Chrome directly for
Chrome Frame, so it's something
we'd have to have a
long discussion.
But, if you think it's
something that we could do, and
should do, I encourage you to
join the mailing list and
we'll think about it.
Any other questions?
All right.
Otherwise, thank you
so much for coming.
And if you have more questions,
I'll be in the hall for
a little bit and we can
talk about them there.
Thank you.